in a story of immense sadness and
mystery
now finally some sort of closure last
night dorset Police confirmed Emiliano
Salah had been identified the body
recovered from the wreckage of a crashed
plane in the English Channel is his
David Dixon the pilot of the plane
carrying the cardiff city footballer
he's yet to be found the operation to
recover his aircraft has ended due to
poor weather conditions Cardiff City and
Emiliano Salas teammates have paid
tributes on Twitter the club said we
offer our most heartfelt sympathies and
condolences to the family of Emiliano he
and David will remain forever in our
thoughts cardiff defender sal bomba said
tragic may you rest in peace while the
club's striker umar may assy said rest
in peace Emiliano Salah forever in our
thoughts the pipe and Malibu plane
carrying Emiliano salad back from his
old club nonce to his new one Cardiff
disappeared over the channel on January
21st for three days a search by air and
sea failed to find any evidence of what
had happened that operation was called
off buts last weekend a crowdfunded
private search was launched within a
couple of hours the plane was located on
the seabed just over 20 miles off the
coast of Guernsey a recovery operation
soon began the twenty eight year olds
body was brought back to Portland Harbor
just after 9:00 a.m. on Thursday morning
an inquest will now take place at
Bournemouth Town Hall both clubs are now
tangled in a financial dispute nan
sebast for the first five million pounds
of Salle's 50 million pound transfer fee
Cardiff want to know more about what
caused the accidents before taking any
action for fans and the grieving
families talk of money more seeming
irrelevance emiliano salad sister Romina
posted this tribute last night your soul
in my soul it will shine forever Martha
Kellner Sky News nonce